[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we have youtuber writer
director visionary soda shop owner
Nashville a Nashville Ian currently in
LA olan rogers this has been a long time
coming a lot of you guys have been
asking to get him on an ear biscuits for
years and today it finally happens I'm
super pumped we are fans the dude he's
done quite a bit he's in a mate that I
mean the headline is he's an amazing
storyteller I mean if you look at his
YouTube videos anything that's labeled
with story click on that and listen to
it watch the guy I mean it's a vlog is
edited like a vlog a video log but it's
not you know why because it's all that
more I mean I we analyze it and we get
his take on what it is and but it's just
it's the ancient art of storytelling
which is is dying man it ancient art of
story yes seriously man what do you just
got a little dramatic I mean it's great
it is really great ball people used to
sit around on porches yeah or fires or
they sat on dryers dirt and mount around
and they would make you tell a story you
know it you know what they would do they
wouldn't watch TV or look at a screen
all right in their palm they would tell
stories yeah it's oral tradition Rhett
it's the ancient art of storytelling
that we're losing but this guy
single-handedly see now I'm getting
overdramatic is single-handedly it's
keeping the tradition alive when it
comes to YouTube he's doing a great job
and he actually under sells himself Olin
does Oh big time we had a great
conversation talked about all the stuff
that he's got going on on YouTube and
off just got married got and lots of
exciting stuff so stay tuned for that
there's exciting stuff for us too oh
yeah we got something very exciting
something that we have never done before
lots of people have asked for it but it
just hasn't worked out it's finally
working out and that is we are going on
tour we are physically showing up at
venues across America yes this is a u.s.
tour only this is not an international
tour that'll have to come later so I
apologize International mythical beasts
but to focus on the positive we are
going to venues and meeting you mythical
beasts in person while we do a show from
a stage it's called the tour of
mythicality and this is not your typical
book tour well it's it's not a it's in
conjunction with the book book but we're
not going to lock tober
november/december libraries and
bookstores and doing book signings no
we're putting on a show in theater
venues around the US and there's gonna
be music there's going to be us bringing
aspects of the book to life in a way
that you can only enjoy on stage well
some of you may get on stage but we're
gonna be on stage yeah there might be
some audience participation you'll be in
a seat or standing or something you'll
be comfortably watching but we think
it's gonna be very different from
anything that we've ever done and we
love doing this kind of thing we love
putting on a show and we just haven't
been able to do anything like this in
years
definitely not since we started YouTube
except for the occasional VidCon
performance or that kind of thing but
this is going to be something very
special and linked tell them where we're
going to be we're gonna be in Huntington
New York which is longer Long Island New
York City New York
Austin Texas Dallas Texas San Francisco
San Diego Los Angeles all in California
Washington DC Philadelphia Portland
Seattle Minneapolis no that's not how
you say that Minneapolis Minneapolis
Indianapolis and Minneapolis but they're
not gonna be in Indianapolis
I think we've I think I've been saying
mini Annapolis my intentions in
Minneapolis Minneapolis Minnesota
there's so many of them
they're small it's one small appleís I
don't know Chicago
Orlando Atlanta and finally a homecoming
in December in Durham North Carolina now
you can go to tour of mythicality com2
see where we're gonna be and when we're
gonna be there and you can buy tickets
starting this Friday at tor mythicality
calm but but this is a big but a big ol
booty to you cheeks if you subscribe to
our newsletter at mythical monthly comm
you can get early access to tickets this
week you can get two scoops go we don't
exactly know when that alert is going to
come but the only way you can get it is
if you're signed up for our newsletter
we're trying every doctor trying to give
perks for being newsletter subscribers I
mean you get all the recommendations of
like the stuff that we're into but early
announcements is something that we said
we were gonna do and so that's a special
group of people who get that email and
were and you should be one of they're
gonna continue to be rewarded for that
so if you want to get some of the first
tickets available for this so this is a
limited tour there's limited seating
available it's gonna be very special
we're gonna put on a show that you're
gonna love and we hope to be proud of
so that's mythical monthly comm tour of
mythicality calm we should tell them
about what we're working on with buddy
system I think that's the that's the big
thing that you know we can we're focused
on all summer is crafting buddy system
season two for you guys and we just we
want to make a point to keep you guys in
the loop as we're working on the
creative process I mean it's I love
working on it because there's and we've
got our hands in every aspect of the
process and it's so different than what
we do the rest of the year because it's
you know it's long-form narrative of
course there's still a song in every
episode every episode is gonna be longer
this time around all the songs gonna be
longer
I don't know cuz we've got to write them
we're starting to write them know I
don't hit the song sure the songs don't
need to be longer yeah but yeah and so
that's what we're kind of focusing on
right now and we actually like like
tonight when we're done we're done with
this we're gonna folk
we got to keep writing songs but we've
been for courting demos and many of you
may know I linked doesn't do the social
media thing quite as much as me and he
hasn't done the Instagram thing in a
couple of years so you may not know that
he also went to Mexico recently when I
was there and I did a little social
media for but we went to different
parties
yes different places so I was with my
wife and he was with his wife we decided
to do it that way this time and we were
in completely different parts in Mexico
anyway it was just a long weekend it was
like a get there on Thursday stay
through Sunday and it was as I called it
from - my wife Jesse it was the calm
before the storm trip it was this is
gonna be a crazy summer just like all
our summers have become crazy now that
we do good mythical morning almost
year-round and we in we do buddy system
or something like it during the summer
and there's always else something else
going on our families don't get a lot a
lot of the traditional things like
there's not like a summer vacation
anymore we have to take vacation over
Thanksgiving or over Christmas or
whatever mm-hmm so it was like baby we
just need some time alone and without
having to worry about any of the
stressors in our lives and so and I need
to be writing songs the whole time yeah
well specifically what I told her I said
all I want to do is sit by the pool I
don't want to do any excursions but I
was like the thing that would be the
most stress relieving for me personally
and also the most helpful for what I
need to be doing is if I could just sit
next to the pool and write songs and she
was totally fine with that because she's
just gonna sit next to the pool and read
a book or work on whatever she happens
to be working on with her design stuff
and so I actually felt like I got more
work done poolside in Mexico then I then
then I ever get done around here I think
we might need to move our office to just
a poolside in Mexico really yeah how can
I oppose that I mean just sitting there
and just waiting for a waiter to ask me
what I wanted next good
there was a guy and the pool I was
beside and he came up and he took my
sunglasses any washed them
did he ask first or he'd take him right
off you ripped him off my face no he
washed no he did he slamming it back on
my face he washed your sunglasses yeah
mm-hmm he didn't charge are you the only
one he was doing that for yeah then he
got they went back to his family and you
know it was just another guest a guest
no that's what he did super super nice
guy taught me some Spanish oh really
I've forgotten it
it went adios but I but I got so much
work done but one of the things that
happened was is I'm I'm at this pool and
I've talked about this on GMM or
somewhere before I don't know how I'm
using this app you know traditionally
I'll write songs on the guitar or piano
which I don't really actually play the
piano but I can play it well enough to
write something very slowly but I've got
this app that's like playing out the
chords I can like select different
chords and just hit buttons to play
chords just to create song structure
without having a piano in front of you
what's it called suggestor suggests
suggestor yeah and I think there's
multiple programs but that's a really
good use you suggested it to me which
yeah it's cause it's suggester there's
no sir it's not suggest but anyway I can
suggest something suggest I think you
suggest something you ingest something
if you eat it I suggest that you listen
to me right now
suggest I suggest I suggest yeah I
suggested it's got two G's in it does I
suck and I just you got to suck a little
bit you gotta just a little bit
anyway I use a gesture but I'm using it
poolside and there's a good promo for
some someone that's not a spa not even a
spa come on suggestor yeah I suggest
that you become a sponsor now they
they're playing music poolside and then
there's yes another person playing their
own music poolside and it's different
beats happening off like an iPhone yeah
well they have like gonna be like
speakers JBL Bluetooth speaker that was
very loud actually a lot like the one
that I have a home why would you do that
if there's music yeah and they're
equally as loud and I'm you're writing a
song I've got my headphones on and I'm
suggesting things to myself ding ding
ding you know different little piano
chords that got old very quickly so we
moved we moved to the other side of the
pool where where they were like this
side of the pool is quieter this is
where there's the saltwater area we
didn't make it all the way to that this
is a place you've art you've been before
yeah you didn't swim in the saltwater
pool I never did I didn't I stayed at
the main pool you're just more buoyant
most of the time but anyway I
accidentally got in the pool one time
there were these must not have been it
was hotter where I was I got I got in a
pool a lot but I was on the beach and I
can still hear music playing and I was
writing the song for episode 2 which I'm
so tempted to tell you what it's about
but it I would say here's my hint it's a
very revealing song or actually not
revealing so yes but I decided to make
it a reggae song hmm
you know wonder why because this music
they're playing was the reggae and I
couldn't get it out of my head so I just
started like I was writing down lyrics
but you start writing down to the rhythm
of like that I'm sure it's this this
song that we that we finalize is going
to be the same tempo and it's certainly
gonna be reggae mine's gonna be two
tempos oh you got yeah you got two
competing tempo simultaneous Ong so um
you know when you hear that song in
episode 2 you guys got the scoop on it
and you you can you can picture me on a
beach in Mexico riding it I'm super
excited about it I know we we talked a
little bit about buddy system season 2
but you know it's come is so crazy just
so weird
it's so weird in a wonderful way I mean
it's just the buddy system is the thing
that we can buddy systems is the is our
outlet for the weirdest ideas that we
have you know GMM is a place where we do
weird things
yeah but buddy system is a place where
we conceptualize and execute and bring
to life weird ideas that are kind of
like an alternate world and the season
two is even weirder and a better in a
better way than season one was I'm
starting to be you were relieved when
you started writing things down I don't
get relieved until we get maybe when we
send a demo to mark but that who's our
music producer but then when he sends
back like a more produced track and it's
like it's all clicked into place then I
start to feel relieved it's like it's
it's interesting how we feel relief at
different parts in the creative process
which I feel relieved I feel relief when
I know that the song is going to be
funny and I know that the song is gonna
sound good
like I've written a verse for that song
and the other song and like this and I
saw just like the templates there but
the second verse is not there yet it's
like I think you'd feel great because
you're like oh I can bang out the second
verse and I'm like do I have a sing a
verse in me and of course we have the
benefit of each other so like you can
also take that and say oh yeah I I see
what you did here in his first verse now
blame I did blame him here's a second
one like you could you could fart that
out alright all four together maybe I
can maybe you hand me something I'm like
oh that little thing that melody there
that was that was the start of something
what if we do blah but a black food and
then I farted that out and then it's
like man this smells funky let's see
guys I can't wait to share it with you
you've really really set the bar pretty
high expertise long sound like beans man
refried beans Mexico okay that's what's
what's one way to see I tend to think of
my my songs is coming from my head not
from my but just my heart in my head
you're probably if yours come from your
butt that's great that would explain six
points I'll take that I'm fine with that
okay so we're gonna get to our
conversation with Olin in just one
second but first we're gonna let you
know about damn pocket
teas that we got Oh actually I got a
pocket tea right here
yeah the official ear biscuit is his
pocket tea look at that you can fit for
your five fingers in the pocket and link
you have a non pocket tea yeah wax paper
dog shirt this is the retro wax paper
dog shirt available for a limited time
rhettandlink.com/store yes that's where
all our stuff is all types of pocket
tees and all types of things to drink
beverages out of yes on vacation and now
on to the biscuit with olan rogers
mm-hmm okay so look Roy used to be trash
yeah like like I think it was like they
used it in like the 70s or something for
airplanes
what do you mean trash it's like trash
water it's it's like really bad quality
water like well I like to what wash
planes no like to serve on planes man to
serve on just yeah just the crappiest
water the Crabbie's water well you know
it was me was we talked about this on a
GMM it was made in the Midwest I think
it was the 80s that's when that yeah
yeah yeah and it's but it's been around
just kind of like flying under the right
foot literally flying over the radar in
planes I don't know how high radar goes
it 40 Saints true and then it's true I
don't think it's changed at all I think
it's just it's perception has changed
it's just a story of perception that's
what Lacroix is story of altered
perceptions it's marketing you know it's
marketing because it's just it's just as
my kid calls it spicy water spicy spicy
water Lacroix spicy water I see water
which to him just he's seven and just
means it's got the carbs
it's got car carbonation those are carbs
right no it does is it different herbs
and carbonation different so you don't
understand the market which is it has no
carbs
it has nothing but hero calories yeah
Shepherd says that toothpaste is spicy
adult toothpaste is well that makes
sense cuz it could be I mean pepper many
are they doing the Lacroix thing in
Nashville or everywhere
yeah okay so it's you
people are obsessed with this now okay
so you didn't just adopt it no it's
coming out here it's all over yes I was
gonna ask my mom if it was in North
Carolina but our friends back in back in
Cary North Carolina they have it they're
doing it yeah they're gonna start
actually replacing it I can put it into
public works that's what I've heard
everybody everybody wonders is
everywhere congratulations on breaking
so much stuff yeah you've got this and
you know what we should talk about all
this but you've got yeah you got this
the cartoon on TBS is happening yeah
shall we call it an animated series yes
you cannot call it a cartoon you can
call it a cartoon you're gonna call it
manga manga manga I don't think it's
manga I don't I don't know how to say it
is it making manga but anime is it manga
that's a that's like the comic version
of anime right yeah yeah I just wanted
to say manga you don't know either manga
you did a comic version but anime would
be it's easy anime no I knew that
already and you got married yes you you
elope that's how you put it yeah so
we'll have to we'll have to unpack a
little bit of that and you moved out
here on your hands at least temporarily
for like a year
oh so how long have you been here in LA
um since November okay okay so through
the holidays yeah but you did like a
tour so you weren't like here over the
holidays um well just for like three
weeks I was gone okay goes back here
what's your assessment of here are you
staying in the Oakwood apartments no no
I'll call them that Ernie do you know
what that is I have no idea what's the
they call it like Toluca something
that's gotten a little fancier again
it's all about perception but the
Oakwood apartments are furnished
apartments that for maybe decades at
least people you know people get a job
and coming to town to do their thing and
then it's you know it'll probably fizzle
out so I'm not gonna bring furniture and
you stay there
where a lot of the child stars who came
out early like back in the day like a
Corey Haim and Corey Feldman
Cory what are your honor but we stayed
there when we when we moved here for six
months to make commercial kinks we
stayed in the Oakwood apartments and
they gave us really the spiel will not
open a there for six months how much
does it cost and we stay there for a
couple of weeks no you're right I'm
sorry
how much does that come we stayed in a
furnished apartment for six months and
that was really but in Los Feliz
that was way or that but when the pilot
for our show on IFC we stayed in the
Oakland Apartments for like three two or
three weeks yeah to like edit the pilot
and all that stuff what was rent at the
Oakwood yeah at that time I don't
remember that it was a little probably
like 25 hundred a month or something
like that for like furnished only for
like yeah and everything really crappy
though okay twenty-five hundred dollars
that's awful and why did you do that I
don't know anybody that's so bad like
well we didn't the production company
actually paid for it they put us up for
the couple of we it wasn't that bad
because when we moved our safe for the
six months we stayed in another place
which was too expensive to but that was
furnished but you're not living there
that's it yeah short answer yes I'm not
yeah I'm not living there yeah because
you know it it's a year you're gonna be
here for at least two what is the
physical address of the place you're
staying
it's just West Hollywood I'm like yeah
what why are you only saying a year
because well we did that saying that was
what we told our families but we thought
we knew we'd never get going back and
they're not listening to tell us no hope
to stay or you're like playing it by ear
or I'm playing it safe yeah just because
I don't know what that future looks like
cuz right now it's I only have like a
season one a final space mm-hmm
there they really really really freaking
like it right now but to move everything
across the country to LA which
everything's like twice the price if not
quadruple oh yeah yeah it's this it's
it's a way different environment plus it
is really like Nashville like it's just
such a nicer place I think and I
give this place a chance I'm trying to
do man I'm trying but and that feels
cool though yeah I've heard it's really
cool in Nashville yeah it is it's a
really cool like soda shop you can hang
out and yeah there's much in there too
okay
so in you and you're I mean you're just
freshly married yeah about two weeks two
weeks
oh yeah okay so tilted you you you
talked about this in your vlog a little
bit yeah about the decision to elope
yeah this is a long time coming um yeah
yeah I mean we've been thinking about it
for a while yeah how long you would you
you were dating like ten years so by a
while you've been a decade 10 10 whole
years yeah so um I mean that I always
kind of imagined getting married when I
was a little bit more mature
I was very immature 20 year old but then
you realized it would never happen so
you just got married anyway
well I think it was something that me
and my now wife discussed and she didn't
really want to get married just because
our parents one of those get married and
our family one of those getting married
mm-hmm and that was the big biggest
pressure especially coming from a lot of
religious people where they're just like
you got to get married at 18 the moment
moment attraction starts you got to get
married so yeah that was more of a thing
where I was like I was gonna wait until
us 30 because I was like that's that's
the guy would it be for the rest of me
oh this is a long-term plan yeah well
then just that part everything else I
don't have a planned well if it you know
if it's tough in the first year don't
worry about it I mean I don't know we
got married young both of us and like I
tell everybody who gets married it's
like if the first year sucks just wait
until the second year but like if you've
been together for 10 years if your
advice doesn't apply so then yeah so
then that's a good test is that if it
sucks for you then
plan is backfired it's basically what
you're saying I did weather a lot of
years of me not being a great husband a
lot I wish I had I had to whether that
Christie had to weather that yeah I I
think I mean since we've been dating for
so long that we are very comfortable and
in who we are right now and it's
something that we know our goals and our
strengths and weaknesses and we we know
each other so I mean even with this kind
of situation where she's in Nashville
right now because we have a house there
and I'm up here kind of trying he's
still back there yeah yeah it's sucks
but I mean it's like we have a bunch of
dogs and it's like a house of business I
mean it's there's a lot to move in that
decision from Nashville to LA mm-hmm and
even still it's it's I mean how do you
move away from your home you know yeah
like I've stayed in Tennessee for the
past over a decade you know
since sixth grade you know so it's like
it's a it's a big decision and I don't
know if it's something especially coming
to a place where everything is way more
expensive and I I just don't know this
area and it's it's very alienating and
even just right now it's it's it's kind
of lonely well I will say that it's
pretty lonely
mm-hmm just because I go into work and I
work on the show and then it's just that
non-stop all right I don't know if you
can you guys have done a show it's like
it's it's unrelenting it's just non-stop
and you want to be the best thing that
you can possibly make and if you you
know at the same time you can't like
especially doing YouTube you can't
neglect that so I devote my week to
doing final space and my weakens to
doing YouTube and I don't get any breaks
so there's no other time now and what's
your wife's name Rachel Rachel the in
the pictures I saw they were like clever
she was cleverly obscured in a couple of
the pictures I saw which made me think
maybe like I couldn't see your face yeah
in the wedding foot so I wanted to
respect you you know if some boundary
was set up that I didn't know about that
is that something that you guys have
done that like does she not have a face
that does she not appear and she doesn't
make videos he's a faceless monster man
no no no she's yeah she's of course she
has face yeah behind the scenes is there
a is there a delineation here or she in
your videos no yeah yeah she's been in
she's in been in multiple sketches that
I've done oh gosh she's been in tons of
videos but you know so in the so I'm
just making this up in my brain then
yeah it's just all yeah I think so we
don't put our wives in in video
someone's that oh maybe maybe he does
occasionally because the the wedding
photo
she's like giving you a kiss but he
can't see I couldn't see her face that's
just the cool thing that you do now man
it's called the silhouette link I don't
I I wasn't the photographer I yeah it's
a great picture
yeah I'm but I see your face I don't see
her face under the same there are plenty
of pictures of her face of her face yes
face I'm not the one I'm not the one who
said she didn't have a face I never I'd
I was never my question right well but
what about this I had a more intelligent
question which was why I haven't a tells
you a question all right I'm not a
pressing question sir and that question
is how do you how are you with somebody
for a decade you got a lot of time to
plan the wedding you got a lot of time
to get all the details right usually you
elope with somebody that you just met
right so the combination of time
together before marriage and quickness
of marriage once the decision to get
married like you care on the opposite
end of the spectrum so how did what went
into that yeah I mean I think it was
just both of us didn't want to have a
big wedding and a lot of that I think
stemmed from her sister getting married
and I just remember after the I think
she called up Rachel who I guess was the
I guess bridesmaid it is that the maid
of honor made of maid of honor
bridesmaid yeah maid of honor maid of
honor I'm sorry which I know about
weddings you didn't have to worry about
that so she called her after the wedding
and was like asking about these cupcakes
that was at the weddings like hey yeah
it's like
we didn't get any cupcakes we're
wondering if there's just any cupcakes
and this was like the day after the
wedding right at her own wedding she
know after the wedding she called her
sister asking about cupcakes that were
at the wedding because she took them
okay
and so I was like what the hell this
your guys just got married you're asking
about cupcakes what's the answer I don't
know the answer to that well she gave
him two we had an event at the soda
parlor and she gave him to all the the
people that came to this event so but
she wanted them she wanted these
cupcakes and she couldn't have them
because you gave him away
the game but their cupcakes they're
supposed to be given away and so that
led you to you don't have it already
there's a bigger story there's a bigger
story here other cupcakes come out to
preface it to preface it give us the
whole story I love your stories look you
tell great story I thank you
so these cupcakes when she asked about
him put my now wife into tears okay
because there was this all the stress
all this like built-up like pressure to
make the perfect day perfect yeah and
there's always a disappointment and
basically to kind of worry about the
most insignificant thing the day after
the day after you marry your now you
know spouse yeah you worry about
cupcakes most ridiculous thing I've ever
heard of my life but did she want to eat
one or did she want to know that they
were good because that's what I thought
you were saying she didn't get one she
didn't get one get one that's because
she's busy like glad-handing I glad
headed everybody hands with everyone you
glad I greeted everyone with a glad hand
you know what I'm talking about
oh yes no I don't actually the excited
have a wedding so what no but by seeing
glad he shouldn't say glad hand again
that's all so something's happening in
your own but your glad-handing people
it's when you're greeting people and
you're being a host and you forget to
eat all the food you don't get it and
you don't remember what have we had
people create a little pack for us like
a picnic basket that we took to the
hotel room and it had a cupcake now see
that's smart that's smart I didn't make
a phone call them through that but day
after you shouldn't be asking about to
connect for any reasons that I don't
still understand what her reason is but
it couldn't be a good one just what
you're saying it couldn't be a good one
and it you shouldn't be worrying about
that you should just be worrying about
you know having fun on a honeymoon or
also just I don't know it just seems
kind of insane to be like literally
putting somebody to tears over something
that insignificant and causing all this
pressure and then you got a plan a
wedding and then who's planning this you
got to do a bride shower you got to do
no bachelor party it's all these like
traditions that it's just built up and
now it's this whole production the whole
product and I've done wedding
photography as well
mm-hmm and once you do wedding
photography holy crap I used to love
photography I can't I can't shoot
photography anymore we did one wedding
yeah you know that was it it's awful
it's awful it's awful it was bad to be
on the on the on the fringe of it you
don't want to be in the middle of that
doughnut yeah I mean it's brilliant what
you did Brody's like your stories man
you did it right you waited five years
and then you just rip the band-aid off
but who was disappointed who was more
disappointed your family her family
nobody nobody cuz they cuz because you
made it clear the cupcake maker
it wasn't a surprise it was like we're
not gonna do this big thing exactly
you're eloping yeah was there any sort
of I mean we did it we did it I think a
little party a very respectful way like
we you know I told me he got dressed up
they had a photo didn't see her face but
they did have a phone they did the
silhouette thing I don't know what
photos are even looking at that's that's
tough to pull up the photo pull it up I
want to see your wedding photo on the
thumbnail I can't see her face either
are you just talking about the thumbnail
of the video I'm talking about the
thumbnail where you said we eloped
don't see your face and then there
there's a picture but you know that that
pic
sure that thumbnail was the exact moment
that we became you know Mary yes
oh really like I can't I can't just like
move the position well that's you
kissing in your wedding ceremony yeah
it's not us yeah
I noticed that her face was obscured and
then on your Instagram that's what I was
looking at no yeah I go to that
Instagram let's see that no pictures of
her face on you let's say that yeah
let's see it
what what is it what my Instagram olan
Rogers Rogers I guess so yeah that's it
I'm scrolling all right there's one
girl's face but efficient way facing
totally away - oh yeah you can see your
face you may not realize that this is
what you've been doing all along look at
that look can't go back no there's
multiple pictures in that click click
into that again click that and go
through it no see that's our broccoli
keep going except broccoli keep going
can you just tell me if that's broth
it's not broccoli why would I keep going
okay link oh oh she has a face third
picture in I never asked if that if she
had a face I just asked if you had a
policy of not posting her face her face
is on there and your policy is you just
bury it oh you bury it deep okay I'm not
trying to come in between the two yeah
your guys creating all kinds of problems
face again dang I don't know how to use
Instagram who knew you could post
multiple pictures in a post okay so
nobody was disappointed
no no regrets which listen man I don't
blame you I mean I had we had it we had
a good time it was a good party I wasn't
ready I didn't have to pay for it I was
a wreck but he was a wreck what's gonna
easily done without it I was it
stressful who when you had yours yeah
but like I mean you know me I feel like
I'm doing it for everybody else and I
want everybody else to be happy that's
it did you like the cupcakes it's about
everybody else
that's that's
right there and it's a production for
everybody and then half the people that
you glad-hand you don't even know you
don't even know thank you
it's pretty much like I put it in the
video a pop-up restaurant that you're
just feeding a bunch of people that you
have no idea who they are yeah but you
can't feed a pizza you can't feed them
like Doritos it's gonna be okay you got
a dream like flaming yawn and like
little croissant
you know seafood lobsters I don't know
just things that no one ever orders when
they go places like you mean if it's
something you wouldn't even order are
you gonna give it to them for free like
it like it's better the thing that you
would never order is better that's yes
suddenly everybody likes some sort of
shrimp thing at their at their wedding
and I wouldn't you know never catering
menu but your and everything what people
don't order right here you want this
yeah it sounds great gonna love it but
you're in a challenging place because
now it's a long-distance relationship
and you're newlyweds and you know what
you're really green out Dule coast and
are you going back Nashville's not on
the coast
I mean it's Tennessee as a landlocked
state well it is it there is a river
there's so much little land once you get
to Nashville relative to the rest of the
thing that you'll if you zoom out far
enough your new coat looks like it's
something out the Mississippi River your
dual coasting yeah I mean are you going
back on a rhythm no we I mean we kind of
visit each other back and forth as much
as I can get out there she'll come up
here for a couple weeks I'll go out
there and then we're pretty used to the
whole long-distance stuff I mean she's
did it a huge internship in in London
and that was like for a year and so she
went to college in Mississippi I went to
college in Memphis that was a year I
mean so we're pretty used to it and yeah
I mean it's it's nothing it's nothing
new it's nothing new okay so yeah ten
years I mean that's what I'm saying it's
like you've been through it they've been
through it so well that's good I'm glad
to hear that
and so let's skip to the to the cartoon
final space yeah when it was Gary's
space yeah that was like just a vide I
mean when you made that video it was
it was it just a one-off was it like
okay I'm calling this a pilot I want to
try to sell this because it's you know
fast forward seven years it's finally
getting made yeah I mean it was just
amazing it was just yeah it was just
something in 2010 where I was like I
just really want to make a cartoon and I
had no money no no real way to make it
so I just decided to just just to do it
it's very crude it's just images moving
across the screen and I did an After
Effects and it was fun it was just that
was just meant to be kind of fun because
I just I love cartoons I've watched
pretty much anything that you can
probably say I've watched it but yet
after it kind of got picked up I was
ecstatic I mean this is something that
I've you know dreamt of I used to draw
comics and and all that so when I was a
kid so this is something that does yeah
something I really wanted for a while so
but so you did the you did Gary space
yeah but then when you last year like
the middle of 2016 when you uploaded
which basically was final space which is
yes but what was the status of the
project at that point because it seems
like you were because you made it and
then months later you you made your vlog
about it getting picked up so yeah it
was such a fast process but but new form
funded the providers up yeah okay all
right yeah a new form funded oh yeah
yeah the proof of concept yeah and so
then what happened after after um put
that up yeah I mean I started getting
messages kind of immediately from lots
of different places Adult Swim Kona Co
Lionsgate all these other people that
just really gravitated towards it for
one reason or next and then yeah after
that it was just a whirlwind where I
just got sucked out to LA started
preparing a pitch pitch to a bunch of
places they all wanted it and went with
TBS so do you meet with Conan himself
yeah because it's usually one of those
things like okay this
this is Conan's company yeah it's like
this is like we we had a lot of meetings
and it's like well you're gonna meet
with Jack Black or you gonna meet with
Ben Stiller and then it's like you get
there and you're like well you're not
you I mean Ben Stiller's company yeah
Jack Black's company you're meeting with
his guy or girl who does that stuff yeah
the development person yep and there's a
little bit of a letdown well I'm looking
in that one meeting III think I asked
his been around oh no no he's in Iceland
we didn't get a meeting but you got to
meet Conan yeah but I mean not the first
time it was just their executives you
know like just a you've glad-handing
Conan after after you had gone with him
or did he have to seal the deal did he
have to come in no he was he wasn't even
he's not even really involved in that
much of the process I just went to one
of his shows and he just said he really
loved what we were doing and I shook his
hand he's super funny super tall yeah
but yeah I was just excited just to talk
to anybody because at that time I didn't
even know what the heck I was gonna be
doing for the next year you know so I
mean I was just like who if it's Conan
great but if it's an executive that just
wants to do something with it yeah I'm
excited
either way yeah the thing that I hear
like under the surface or I mean
sometimes I think you just say it
outright when you talk about in a lot of
YouTube videos being like the underdog
but like the one counted out or the one
who's yeah who's not making it who's
like giving it all he's got and it just
kind of fizzles out yeah yeah like you
describe yourself that way the underdog
I mean I don't you don't call yourself a
loser but it it seems that way but then
it's you know for me and everybody that
watches I think it's it's quite the
opposite it you're like the hero that
like actually try stuff you actually
make stuff you do stuff though and it
seems like it does work so it's like so
like this I'm gonna start a soda
yeah in Nashville I'm gonna have a merch
company yeah well you have these things
but I think it's it's what you're seeing
is the the end result you know like the
process from starting you know from
nothing all the way up to that how many
freaking times I failed to try to get
that thing off the ground like the
struggle to open up that first soda
parlor I mean
we about like went broke a couple times
had to take loans out had to you know
scrap in in Just's cabbage anything that
we could to open those doors and that
was like I mean probably one of the
hardest things till this day that I have
ever done you know it still sounds like
a crazy idea it's a crazy idea it's
working it's doing great we opened up in
a bigger spot which by the way is the
beauty of it I'm not like saying this a
negative it's like this is a big crazy
idea yeah what I mean so you've said
that like four times every time we meet
you're like that's such a crazy idea I
love it I love it when somebody has a
crazy idea and they do what how did that
come about
why did a free pizza party meetup tour
back in like 2013 and pizza party meetup
- so this is for like your YouTube
audience yeah yeah I cuz I got asked to
go to playlist and I was pretty pissed
that he whoever it was went through
Mitchell Davis just to ask me and
couldn't ask me just in person and I was
like that's so shady and then that at
the time that they decided to ask me it
was like the maximum amount that like
ticket price so it was like over $100 to
get a ticket to go to playlist so if I
went people would have had to pay that
price I was like this is that's insane
like I'm not gonna ask somebody to pay a
hundred bucks to come to playlist that's
like I'm not doing that
so I decided to do my own thing and just
do it for free and we spent like over
ten thousand hugs and pizza and just
sold merged basically fun
the next stop and we did eight stops
around the u.s. and like over 8,000
people came to it
like 13 our meetups 13 our meetups yeah
well you know was that it was 2013 I
think okay yeah what is the 13 hour what
are you doing for 13 hours meeting
people like to like people laughs
handing you glad-handing peak you like
people lining up I don't know it was it
was it was meeting people I think it
wasn't glad having it was like like
meeting talking you know doing whatever
they wanted me to do for a picture
dancing I mean it was it was a lot of
fun in from that experience I realized
wow if I could if I could connect to
these people and actually know these
peoples and names you know like create a
place where people could come and I kind
of it's like a shorthand to where they
don't even they don't even want to take
a picture with me anymore
I was really intrigued by that and and
we started thinking about trying to do
open up something that essentially could
could do that a place where we could do
these events and you know host a game
night or a pizza party or something like
that and that's kind of where the soda
parlor got birthed I mean we would do a
coffee shop but I know nothing about
coffee and it would probably be really
terrible coffee so we just did sorta
because it was easy and and floats and
yeah I mean it was we could have done
more but our first business our
next-door neighbor basically was very
threatening to us and would basically
said that he was right when we opened
our doors he was like I'm the I'm the
king of beverages in this building and
you can't do anything and so basically
he he saw his competition he owned a
restaurant or a bar some a coffee shop
and so basically of coffee
basically all beverages when I met with
them me and my business partner met with
them and I mean this guy was sitting up
like you know five feet higher than us
on a throne I'm like a throne okay yeah
the beverage King throne yeah and he had
like
all these monitors of stocks next to him
and we're sitting there completely low
like looking up to this guy and he was
like come in and I'll I'll give you some
advice on how to open up a business you
know run it like I'm sure you know and
we sat there and he starts like leaning
in his chair freaking the thing snaps
and he eats it he eats it and Rhonda's
like oh my gosh like I'm looking at
Coulter and he's about to break and that
finally I'm talking it wasn't like it
wasn't like it like a fall it was the
chair spine snapped in half oh my gosh
did he die and he ate it he got up his
face was red and he was like so and he
stands there and he's like what else do
you got oh he didn't say I meant to do
that he acted like it didn't happen
it was worst and so I was like oh man
this thanks for all the help and stuff
but after that he basically ended up
putting a soda thing in his coffee he
thought and then he thought you'd
already trapped his chair man yeah and
then he started no-tilling soda yeah I
started selling soda and doing floats No
yeah and so how before we opened
essentially before you open yeah and it
but this is the old location yeah he did
it he met with us essentially to steal
our idea essentially and so you did it
for how long at that location a year a
year and a half but it was a struggle
because of him I mean we we were doing
very well I mean he he was just a
douchebag but I mean he didn't really
affect us at all but it was just the
fact that there's this guy that just
anything that we did he would tell the
landlord you know the landlord wouldn't
fix anything are basically there's
termite problems I mean it's the list
can go on about that location but it was
it was a struggle but that guy was
douchebag man and and these are all
things that you are talking to your
viewers about you're like letting them
in on well yeah I'm just yeah on your
experience as it's happening yeah
because I
want to make it seem like it was
sunshine and rainbows man it was it was
it was dirty and it's a very dirty
process to run a business which I'm sure
you guys know it's hard it's not an easy
thing to do and in that time you know
when you're trying to open up a business
you got to worry about other people and
their families and and they're depending
on you to make this thing happen and
it's it's a lot of work it's a lot of
pressure and it's a lot of stress and
after I ended up opening that I even had
like health problems man it's just some
mask man
it's a mess but I'm glad what it's doing
now it's it's it's a success I would say
it's a success
it's we're still paying off loans and
stuff but it's it's something that we
did without any investors and we just
did it with you know the idea of like
let's us go out and do something cool
and has it transitioned I mean if the
whole thing kind of started as almost
like let's take what we created on the
road and bring it into one place yeah
that seems like something that would be
difficult to maintain for a long period
of time
yeah even even now especially when
you're out here yeah so is it kind of is
the focus changing no no I think it's
and that's one thing that my wife does
now she's you know she's the general
manager of that thing and okay it would
not run without her she designed it
actually she's an interior designer and
you know does a lot of architecture
stuff and but you kind of structured it
where it's it's not all about you so
when you sit out of it exactly or you
know you're not in all the merch photos
that's not your merch it's not your soda
yeah so to speak it's something that you
gave to people it's what it's exactly
and that was a big thing of trying to
make happen which is essentially was it
for it to be a real business it needed
to function without me mm-hmm
being there all the time essentially but
I mean anytime that I'm there I try to
do like a fan appreciation night as much
as I can get up there which is we just
give out free floats and free pizza and
I mean we'll go through
at least like $3,000 in ice cream I mean
alone man
it's it's fun though but I mean the
thing is like it's it's always a way
just to kind of give back to the people
that have supported me and that thing
wouldn't be running without the people
that come in there and support it so
right it's just a way to kind of do
something fun for them so right before
that what was the first thing that
worked like I'm like I can trace back
like the first story and it's kind of
hard to tell now like the stories get so
many views yeah and so it's kind of hard
to tell going back to the beginning how
many of those are like views of people
going back versus which one really
popped first yeah and I know you had a
sketch channel with a friend of yours
yeah or that
yeah yeah and I kind of look at that you
say okay he was doing just weird
sketches that some of those have
millions of views too yeah so did
something pop there first or was it and
then you switch to the stories I mean I
kind of basically won once I left
balloon shop which was the sketch thing
yeah with yeah friend we kind of all
went our separate ways
and I had to restart a channel for
nothing essentially and I started doing
the the stories and stuff it wasn't
until man I don't even know I think it
was it was definitely after I got done
with a tour the dial-up tour and I
posted ghosts in the stalls and that was
probably the one that I mean in terms of
what viral is now it didn't really go
viral but it got a ton of views I mean
it like that was like my first like
million views like oh yeah I gonna day
essentially and then after that one it's
just I've always been kind of like a
slow burn where it's like it's just a
very slow process I mean you look at me
out it I'd you know I've been on YouTube
for man
like 11 12 years and I still haven't
cracked that a million code yet but oh
and subscribers yeah yeah
but it's not a big deal proving that
doesn't matter
yeah exactly yeah because I think that
there's a is this a it's yeah it's a
very just think there's a different
quality yeah to the community that
you're building exactly yes maybe
somebody would with more subscribers
yeah
because even think in the way that you
think about the the fans in the way that
you thought about playlists and the way
that that led to the soda shop it's a
different kind of community that you're
cultivating exactly yes yeah that's even
more personal then I mean first of all
it's it's already very personal when
it's on YouTube yeah it's always it's
already very much more personal than it
is when the traditional celebrity but
you're kind of like yeah ratcheting it
up
yeah well it's it's I mean coming from
somebody that I mean just to preface
that you know I haven't you know I
consider myself an underdog because I
mean I literally have not won really
anything besides like pitching that show
and people all these people wanting it
that was the first time in my life that
people were like oh my gosh this could
actually work mm-hmm
because usually stuff just deteriorates
or it doesn't happen or I get last place
or you know I'll do a video contest and
somebody swoops in and gets all pro
skaters to devote for them and it's just
like sounds like that actually happened
it did happen this sounds very specific
yes it's it's what contest was that by
the way what was it a skateboarding you
know no it wasn't actually it would just
it it's in the past I don't I was so
frustrated what what brand was it for
Nikon okay all right we don't we can
move on yeah I mean it's it's I don't
know I I think it's it's always been
something where I've just lost me and I
I losing everything I've I just I hate
to say it but it's like I just I haven't
ever succeeded in in regards of like
what people can consider traditional
success if that makes sense but it
hasn't stopped you from trying a lot of
different things I mean like no no no I
haven't even gotten to the fact that you
wrote a book
yeah yeah well it's not even out yet but
I'm still working on it yeah you're
writing you're writing a book yeah like
a science fiction well under a different
name
yeah under a different name which is RS
hammer snow okay details of that it is
me my friend Jake it's me our friend
Jake you're both are as hammers now yeah
okay but what what like I think
something people would be interested in
is because you're you you do so many
different things you so many different
things yeah somebody's out there
listening who's like well I've got all
these things I want to do but I but he's
actually done all these things you say
you're underdog and I'm not saying that
those things haven't been difficult and
everything that hasn't been a huge
success but you've done so many
different things you're doing so many
different things well like what do you
say to somebody who's like how do i how
do I start something you just got to do
it man
a lot of those things like that book I
don't have any book deal nobody I mean
somebody did ask me to kind of do like a
biography on myself and I was like nah
I'm not interested I'd rather just do
fiction if I was gonna do anything and I
mean yeah there's nothing lined up for
that you know I'm not I just wanted to
do it you know for the soda parlor
nobody was like hey here's here's half a
million dollars go open yourself a soda
parlor we just did it we took out loans
and we got ourselves in debt just to
open that up and do something cool and
it's paying itself off and it's actually
pretty cool to watch even with my videos
and stuff like that like I mean a lot of
that stuff I just kind of went out and
did it
and a lot of them have supported it but
you know from the beginning of that
channel it's been I started from zero
you know and it's just been constantly
doing it you just got to go out and do
it essentially yeah to me it's like mmm
being willing to take a risk and another
risk in another risk I mean exactly
every you know creative endeavor I think
has a there's an element of risk
associated with it if it's legitimately
something that from your from an
artist's heart yeah he or she wants to
create exactly and then I think you you
just add oh just a level of
vulnerability to it yeah that you should
you know that becomes part of your art
as well that you're sharing yourself and
it's not just okay so I've got I might
have a great story today yeah but then
tomorrow I've got I've just got myself
like what's your philosophy on crying on
camera like you had that you had the the
sunglasses bit for the for for like the
tears of joy when you were announcing
like the final space being ordered yeah
series but that's not the first no no no
no no no way I'm just a very emotional
person to begin with man you know I'm
that kind of person as a kid that you
know watch Titanic and bawling his eyes
out you know or Braveheart when when he
says freedom I was like weeping you know
my dad was like it's okay to cry and
like but what he's not crying of course
oh no he's saying it's okay for you to
cry yeah yeah meet occur yeah I've just
been I just been that person man I don't
know I can't describe it any other way
when it comes to crying in camera it's
not like I go into it thinking I'm gonna
cry I'm gonna cry I'm gonna weep I'm
gonna weep in this I like physically try
not to cry it seems like you were trying
not but then on the backend who's
editing who's that any of these videos
me so at that point you got a decision
to make it's like you could you they'd
scrap the whole thing you could put only
the crying in you could put a teaser of
just crying like boom right off the bat
he's like weeping look at why I don't
want to put a teaser of cry I'm saying
it would be horrible I'm presenting the
extremes of your choice as the editor
yeah you could start with crying or you
could cut it out entirely so well if I
that's an interesting thing if I cut it
out let in it here's the thing I
actually cut out a lot of the crime
a lot of the stuff that it's in there
it's like it's real you know and if I
take that out am I literally taking out
something that was a real moment during
my recording of that video so a lot of
the times when it comes to that crying
stuff I just let it be its thing and
then I'll move on to the next thing but
I mean if I feel something generally
like I'm sitting there and I'm talking
and it's I'm literally happy to the
point I'm crying in tears that's a
beautiful thing you know it's like I'm
gonna I'm gonna that needs to be seen
that needs to be shown that's that's me
and I want to look back on that in back
Wow
you know that's I remember that moment
that was a really special moment where I
was so excited that I literally could
not contain myself and even with the
soda parlor in you know the eat of
sliced little documentaries that I made
I look back on that and I I watch it and
I'll still cry cuz it's like I remember
that moment and I remember what I was
going through in that moment but to cut
it out entirely I mean you should see
how much of it I did cut out well it's
interesting cuz there's another element
to with there's obviously a whole lot of
authenticity in that yeah and you share
what you're actually thinking what
you're feeling you know show what you're
feeling by actually showing that you cry
at the same time you have this kind of
character that you go into in your vlogs
hmm
so like how did that develop I mean the
the thing with you know doing stories
there's there's definitely two sides of
me and if I love to entertain people and
I love to have fun but there's a lot of
times that I just I'm like the most
chill person that you could probably
even meet you know is there's times that
I just I just need just switch it off
and just just play video games or just
you know not talk to anybody but doing
those those you know video logs that's
me you know that's that's not a
character's it's that is me yeah in in
in essence you know and that's just like
my energetic crazy side the
next slide you know when I'm when I'm
very concentrating the business side the
guy that's like you know doing final
space I have to kind of reserve that
because nobody is gonna give a show to
an insane person you know and I've even
seen that you know it's it's it's you
just kind of got a kind of have both
sides of the coin essentially right
but it is interesting as a I don't know
maybe not as a viewer but as a producer
I think this is what's behind your
question is that the dynamic of I I
understand as a performer that and you
know I I tap into the things that the
aspects of my personality that are that
are more amped up and that are more
performance oriented yeah you know to
entertain and connect with our audience
yeah good morning
but you it's I think it's fascinating to
us how you can it's it is it's I think
that's what we describe is like a
character characterization of ourselves
on good mythical morning that then feels
separate from what we do here on air
biscuits like when like a moment of
honesty but so I think we're fascinated
how those things you switch in and out
of it if those like both those things
happen like it'll happen with a you know
if I can tell that you said something it
came out in a way that you found funny
that you didn't anticipate you were
gonna say so then you crack up and
there's a little you leave a little bit
of that in the edit yeah
which is a great moment of authenticity
but but to me that's that's breaking
character yeah right and then in another
moment you might be moved to tears
you're telling the story and like in in
your your story persona that's just what
I'm gonna call it mm-hmm
or character and then you'll you'll have
an emotional moment which I feel like is
the other side that you're talking about
mm-hmm but just skip back and forth if
that's something that I mean how do you
interact with that how do you how do you
explain it
um
yeah honestly that's not even I don't
even analyze it man I just I just do it
I mean that's just me you know like like
I can't really describe it because it's
something that when I do those those
stories when I crack up it's genuine you
know cuz it's it's something that I'm
remembering back as a kid and it caught
it catches me off guard and I'm like you
know that's funny you know that's that's
I'm laughing at the ridiculousness of
this I don't know I I don't know I can't
I can't really describe it because it's
not something that I sit down and plan
or you know think I'm just gonna do this
you know like I'm gonna be energetic
here and then quiet here it's like I
just you just turn the camera is turn
the camera right if you think of it like
that I don't know like if we go to like
grade school when we talk about like the
class clown yeah
stereotype well that's all you know a
lot of people would say well the my
first guess is that's that's a defense
mechanism or that's a that's a that's a
way to hide how you really feel or maybe
for me and bullied or something like
that now I'm not saying that for you or
for us but I'm just saying I think
that's what makes it fascinating that
when I watch your videos that there's a
there's the performer that's saying
something hilarious but then you're not
high it's very clear that you're not
hiding anything so I think I think
that's because I don't I don't have
anything to hide you know like write
your night yeah you in your subject
matter you're putting everything out
there so that but I think that's what
that's also fascinating I think that's
what people are drawn to you didn't ask
me to try to explain it yeah and I may
be totally off but I don't know I think
that's what draws me well yeah I think a
way to say what you're saying is it say
what I'm saying is that your content is
driven by things that are actually
happening in your life like this light
of it precipitates this piece of content
where where was what we do
with the good mythical morning it's this
is a daily show that's gonna come out
five times a week it's gonna come out
most of the year and you've got to have
something that kind of fits a certain
tone every single day so we're not
waiting for a moment or if something to
happen that then we respond to but we're
trying to get ahead and plant and plan
this show which kind of leads to my next
question which is have you ever thought
about like when you see all these people
doing these daily videos and these daily
vlogs was there a time like what's the
the highest frequency that you've ever
gotten to with your videos and like
what's kept you from going to like a
daily video well daily videos something
that genuinely does not interest me at
all
I think it's it's a lot about there's
there's only so much you can do in a day
there's if it was if I did daily vlogs
it would be very boring stuff I mean I'm
not like I I I think that if you have an
awesome life like you know he'll get a
casein a stent it was just like wow I
mean I'm not that cool you know like at
the end of the day it's like he does
like everything I'm just not that cool
so it's a it's something that a I would
have to like fake it in order to like go
off and do crazy stuff every day which I
don't want to do because it's not me or
two I film a lot of just boring stuff of
me you know writing or just doing normal
everyday stuff like every other human in
the world you know which none of those
interests me so it's just something that
if I'm gonna do something I'm tend to do
it I try to do the best I can and I
don't think I can do daily vlogs very
well right of course that there's
there's I see what you're saying like
there's there could be something there
essentially with that but I don't know I
don't know if I could keep that up I
don't um you wouldn't be able to do the
other stuff that you're doing yeah and
we couldn't we may we have a Daily Show
but we can never do daily vlogs like not
in a million years yeah and there's
there's a lot of stuff that you just
want to keep private man
yeah I can't show my whole life because
I don't want to you know like yeah
there's stuff you know even with my
relationship that it's like you know
maybe I just want to watch a scary movie
with my wife and not film it in in you
know try to to make that an entertaining
thing for people to watch like I just
wanna which is why you know let's show
her face honey think you've made a good
choice with that oh she has one I think
yeah she's got a great face and you I
guarantee you look at Instagram there's
plenty of pictures of her face okay yeah
you're right I saw some of them yeah I
do remember that from earlier
conversation so with final space it's
taking up your your weeks now yeah
you're doing your channel on the weekend
you're fitting it in I mean what what
else what else is in the works what are
you excited about yeah the well the book
is on the backburner just cuz my mic
cord best friend has lines disease so
really yeah right now he's going through
some pretty serious treatment in Kansas
City so I didn't want to go forward with
it until he got better and what's the
what's the prognosis I don't mean it's
it's pretty serious
I mean yeah his basically his
depersonalization it's affecting his
mind it's went past the brain blood
barrier mm-hm
so I think recently like the symptoms
kind of change and he gets new ones like
he went partially deaf and basically I
mean it's it's it's pretty nuts I mean
he if you see the video if you go to his
channel I mean it's affecting his speech
like what's his channel
it's just Jake Sidwell okay so I tried
to set up a I set up a little GoFundMe
for him and he's seeking treatment and
in Kansas but yeah the the book is gonna
wait until that man gets better cuz I
don't want to do anything without him so
okay and well you know we'll put the
link out there too and you know the
video for the GoFundMe yeah that'd be
awesome I mean he's he's a great guy and
and I just really hope he he gets better
I mean it's it's been going
for like over a year started with like
Bell's palsy his half his face was me
realized and it's it's a it's a crazy
disease man I I didn't know much about
it but absolutely didn't come from a tic
it did with yeah it had to have yeah so
other stuff though it's it's just you
know potentially working on stuff just
for like a feature and other animations
and I did another project with new form
and animation called lines plays and
they kind of kind of holding on to it
right now it's under wraps so you can't
see it it's not on the channel it should
be coming up on in August hopefully
because it's it's been done for about a
year now so and then final space he's
coming at 2018 2018 yeah you know what
the first part I think like first
quarter how many episodes 10 okay yeah
and it's just serialized
you know really epic animation half-hour
episodes yeah and how far along are you
in the process right now we just started
I think we have two more scripts to
finish and then we just started records
on five and then the animatics have
started on one and two so it's I mean
it's full production right now and it's
uh it's a lot of work man I did how
naive I was about doing a TV show but
it's it's it's a ton of work yeah cuz
your voice in how many characters even
voicing right now and voice seeing three
because I can only voice three and then
you're in your you've written these
right or co-written them which ones the
episodes pretty that's that's where it
gets kind of interesting with the whole
credit stuff a lot of the scripts were
heavily heavily rewritten to where there
were no words from the previous draft by
me and the showrunner but I mean it's
it's like and you're a producer you're
just wearing a lot of hats yeah
well man we wish you the best we're
we're thing for that you took a break to
come in here and hang out with us and uh
yeah we're fans keep it up man do this
man
yeah any notes for us no I got no notes
for you that's it man that's all there
you have it our biscuit with olan Rogers
um definitely a fan of his you know I
don't watch a lot of YouTube videos but
um I I've watched some of his that's a
disclosure I'm like I really like this
guy and it was so it was really cool to
hang out with him you know I think he's
got a way of connecting like magically
through that camera that like it's a
gift if you start giving people sweets
though I mean it is cheating a little
bit you give people an ice cream and
pizza
oh yeah well maybe we maybe we should
start you know people like yeah I mean a
good story
check out his YouTube channel listen to
all of his stories if you haven't
youtube.com slash olan rogers that's
also his Instagram handle which he
posted pictures of he and his wife's
face his wife's face guy's son that our
pride just his wife's face who knew who
died who knew well I know who did most
people did know I didn't mean to make
such a big deal out of I'm now tell me
we kept going back to it I'm tell me
you're really trying to keep her on the
down-low
what you didn't know you know acting
like my question was weird but we don't
do it so it was a normal question for us
but as soon as I'd looked at as soon as
I saw his response I was like did links
links got the wrong idea see how long
link keeps going up this tree hey but
the first two pictures I showed the guy
did you see your face yeah I took five
minutes I knew it would okay well and
you can you can we don't really have any
peace
our ice cream available currently what
we do have is we have the option for you
to go over to wherever you're enjoying
this podcast and however you respond in
that place if it's iTunes write a review
or give a rating well you know whatever
you do just give us your feet show it
show some love to the near biscuit
hashtag ear biscuits do it we'll see you
next week yes talking toes ears
[Music]